Did you ever wonder about that closed door
in Cathedral Ward? You know the one, it's below the church giant with the ball and chain
and past the room where you rolled through all the pots
It's the sort of door you forget about even if you finish the game
But think about it now You never open that door. Did you? Well, you're not alone?
No one's opened this door yet and perhaps. No one ever will but we do know where it leads
The cliff we're on
Overlooks the Great bridge where we fought the Cleric Beast and it's no great leap of logic to assume this door is the same door
as the one at the end of the bridge
But what is interesting to note is that From Software actually put the effort in to make these two doors align perfectly in the world
Let's prove it. Go over to the door and throw down a couple of shining coins- actually throw 40
This is the only time in the game these are useful go crazy with it then run all the way to the great bridge without
Reloading your game and the door at the end
Will have your shining coins on it still. Which proves that these parts of the world are connected in both the lore and physically
Chances are you could probably unlock this shortcut once upon a time, but in the game's current state
It doesn't make much sense for it to exist so they must have only removed half of it.
While we're in Central Yharnam
Let's go over the things I missed last episode because you guys taught me a lot.
So during this fight with Gascoigne
You would have found the red jeweled Brooch
up on His wife's corpse you take this brooch to their daughter, and she'll cry upon realizing that both her parents are dead
Alternatively if you smash the brooch to get the gem you can talk to the girl and send her to the Chapel just
past Gascoigne's boss fight
but most of you probably already know that the interesting thing is what can happen next so whichever one you chose reload your game and
You'll realize that she's left her house she's now left for the chapel, but you never actually see her show up there, right?
So where did she end up? Well, this little girl crept along through the sewers
Only to be consumed by the giant pig at the end of this long dark Tunnel the proof of this is that the pig now
Drops the Red Messenger Ribbon with the red color drawn from the organs of some unfortunate victim
A strange choice, But perhaps for the messengers wearing this accessory
Constitutes some form of mourning oh, and dude
Did you know that if you summon Gascoigne and bring him to His daughter's window in Central Yharnam nothing happens?
There was someone in the last video's comments, who said I had to try that out
dammit, I'm so hopeful something would happen
But that's something you might not know you can summon gascoigne for help against the cleric beast
If you use the summoning bell right outside the central Yharnam Lantern but
We were supposed to be talking about Cathedral ward
So let's go up the path that the Chief Hunter Himself would have used
after you defeat the cleric beast and buy his emblem from the messengers You can unlock the main Gate by
Inspecting it when you walk through though cast your eyes down to the pavement you can actually see an eye
engraved in the stone
And I think this is a bit of a clue because I think it means that if you have enough insight
You'll actually be able to see the messengers that are gathered around the lever
It's almost like the messengers here
Recognize the item you bought from the messengers in the dream and pull the lever for you since this is the only lever I'm aware
Of that has messengers crowded around it like this
Cathedral ward in General is one of those places that reveals a ton of new details if you have enough insight with 15 insight
church doctors are revealed to have eyeballs crowded around their lanterns and their sights become imbued with more power and
The doctors with the Crucifix have it covered in flame as well
If You have 40 insight, You are able to see the giant Cthulhu Monster that's been hanging off the church this entire time
That's the thing that grabs you when you try to pick up the hunter set in the courtyard
Anyway once you've opened the main gate You can trigger Eileen the Crow's second appearance by opening the gate
That's just next to the wooden plank shield she's hard to spot
But she's standing just below the giant CtHulhu monster outside the front entrance to Oedon Chapel
She tells us of Henryk who is a hunter who's currently residing in the Tomb of Oedon
And that's where you killed Gascoigne. Gascoigne was an old friend Henryk's, and now Henryk has gone mad with grief
Presumably after realizing that Gascoigne passed away
it's Eileen's job to put him down because as we saw with Gascoigne Hunters who go mad are a threat to everybody and
Hunters turn into the most horrific beasts
she gives you the "Shh"
Gesture here and tells us to keep it a secret
so naturally we reload our game and decide to blunder into the Tomb of Oedon here Eileen is patiently waiting to
Assassinate Henryk, that's two against one here
But the real difficulty comes from not actually hitting Eileen while you're trying to kill Henryk if you're not careful
You can actually make Eileen hostile to you
which is not a good thing because she does talk to you afterwards, killing Henryk unlocks his set for purchase in the dream and
Eileen will give you the approval gesture
Eileen is just one of the many NPCs in Cathedral ward though
There are so many in this area
It's probably one of the most densely populated areas to find all these NPCs
You just need to move most of them to Oedon Chapel
So after you've talked to the dweller he'll beg you to ask others to seek the Chapel as a safe haven
and the first NPC that you can recruit is the old woman from Central Yharnam
Who is just before the rafters above the sewers she's useless in the Chapel right now
But after killing seven bosses she starts giving you sedatives and starts treating you like you're her child
And after you've killed three bosses
Ariana and the skeptical man can be sent to the chapel as well, you find them off to the left
Immediately after you've unlocked the main gate with the Chief Hunters Emblem and during this long, Misty street
send Ariana to the Chapel to continue her quest line and then go to the opposite house and talk to the skeptical man if you've
Talked to Josefka in her clinic you'll have two options here the man will go to the opposite of whatever you tell him to
Do so tell him to go to yourself Josefka's clinic, and he'll go to the Chapel
I'm not going to tell you why right now, but you do want him in the chapel, not Josefka's clinic
We'll get to that later.
For now though go down this alleyway
And make sure you pick up the black church Hunters set while you're here
Because we need it to recruit one more NPC a little bit later after you've killed the Blood Starved Beast in Old Yharnam
Snatchers will appear in your world the easiest one to get to is right outside the front entrance of Oedon Chapel
Off to the right and around the Corner die to it on purpose
And then you'll awaken in the Yahar'gul jail then travel down the stairs to your right
And you'll come across Adela put on that black church Hunter garb we picked up earlier in the alleyway
And she'll come down to the point where you can send her over to Oedon chapel if you decide to withhold information
She'll be found dead later in the streets near a pack of dogs
So now we have five NPCs in our Chapel and all of them have very interesting
interactions with each other first off the skeptical man will give you information on every character in the
Chapel as you play through the game an interesting thing about this is as with everything. He says the exact opposite is true
when you talk to Ariana
She'll give you a vial of her special blood which will heal you instantly as well as give you extra stamina regeneration
For a short time afterwards it states that a member of the old healing church would know that her blood
Is similar to what was once forbidden
Adela from the healing church does actually notice this and clearly hates Ariana one of the freakiest things I discovered
Was that when you talk to Ariana
Adela will actually turn her head from where she's sitting and watch you two talking like she's jealous of you
That's really weird when you go and talk to adela. She won't give you her blood if you're carrying Ariana's blood
She's that jealous in fact if you consume ariana's blood more than three times after Killing Vicar Amelia
Adela Will Murder Ariana out of Jealousy
Adela's blood gives a health boost and then continues to regenerate your health twenty seconds afterwards you need to be careful of
Consuming more than three sedatives from the old woman as well because once she gives them to you
She will leave the chapel to go outside to look for more, and that doesn't end well
He find her corpse near some graves later on and we haven't mentioned this door yet
I don't think the one on the right side of the chapel after the Blood-Starved Beast is Dead
It will open allowing you to continue into the church Workshop and pick up Ludwig's holy blade
However if you run around to the left or right of the ground level you can actually drop down to two
Secret areas the first secret area is the abandoned old workshop
Which you can access by going forward here, then turning left and walking slowly off this platform
and then you'll land perfectly near the door the second area is at the bottom and it's a secret Little village that loops back into
Cathedral ward and also allows you to bypass the door that requires
the Chief Hunter Emblem to open you end up here near the wooden plank Shield gate and
If you go over the ladder you'll find the numbing mist which is an item we're going to need for the next boss
Amelia is very difficult and probably not someone you should tackle as soon as you arrive
she has this huge variety of attacks, a gigantic health pool and
the ability to heal and if I had to give quick tips for her
I'd say that you should spend a few fights learning her moveset
And then when you're ready you bring 20 blood vials you bring weapon buffs
and most importantly
numbing mist
When she's at about 30% health this numbing mist will stop her from healing you have six of these at this point in the game
And you need to use them wisely if you intend on killing her with a very un-upgraded weapon
as soon as you touch the skull the night actually progresses
And it becomes darker and a few elements in this area have changed most importantly in my opinion
You can get the Logarius Wheel now it's one of my favourite weapons
Alfred has moved to his second location and now that he's in his second location
He has an extra dialogue option
and
He drops the wheel hunter badge if you kill him here if you want to try and kill him and get the wheel this early
In the game I recommend You should watch this video
I made on how to get every weapon as quickly as possible You can check that out here
But that's pretty much it guys we've got two more videos coming up this week one is things you missed in the hunters dream
Another is things you missed in Old Yharnam, and these are both two like, really easy to make videos for me
So I'm going to get those out as soon as possible
Because I want there to be content that's out there and being released while I work on some lore videos and the lore videos are
Going to be great for this game. We've got three lore explained videos coming up
We've got prepared to cry coming up
And I want to spend a long time working on these so I hope you look forward to it and enjoy the other content
That's going to be going on in the meantime
But thanks for watching and I'll see you next time
(Subtitles done by A Trash Can, and no I'm not joking that's my name, A Trash Can)